depuis un an près de 28000 demandeurs
d'asile sont entrés au canada en passant
par le québec 65 % ces gens là ont
demandé un permis de travail qui sont
subvenir à leurs besoins
du moins le temps que le fédéral prat
leur demande
en un an le fédéral a donc reçu
précisément 18 1109 demande de permis de
travail provenant de demandeurs d'asile
arrivés au québec
à peine 5 % de ces demandes de permis
travail ont été refusées principalement
en raison d'examens médicaux et complet
reste maintenant l'importante question
des délais cette question est importante
parce que plus les délais de livraison
sont longs plus les demandeurs d'asile
vont rester longtemps aux crochets de
l'état parce que les conventions
internationales obligent le canada et
les provinces à offrir une aide de base
aux demandeurs d'asile comme le logement
ou l'aide sociale l'automne dernier pour
obtenir un permis de travail
un demandeur d'asile devaient attendre
entre trois quatre mois depuis janvier
le délai a été réduit à 22 jours si le
délai plus court c'est parce que ottawa
en maintenant dédié une équipe de
fonctionnaires qui gère uniquement les
demandes de permis de travail des
demandeurs d'asile mais est ce que cette
équipe pour en maintenir les délais à 22
jours ci une importante vague de
migrants arrivent à la frontière comme
on le prévoit cette équipe